you know what i would love here's what i
would love if if a if a actuary if a bi
is listening to this if a business
analyst is listening to this if a guy
that studies statistics can listen to
this take time and make this video this
video can actually happen take all the
mass shootings of the last five ten
years okay
create the profile of everybody uh that
did the mass shooting
put their age how they got their weapon
if they were on medication their
background put it all at the top and
filter it out and then take the new
policies and changes that's coming up
and then
read out the ones that could have been
prevented and green out that the ones
that would have happened no matter what
right and kind of go through it and
break down in a video what that
percentage comes down to because i think
the way they're going they're just
playing politics and the american people
are like oh awesome we passed something
yeah it really didn't do anything no no
but we did pass something no really
didn't do anything i think we need data
and we need somebody to analyze this
like a statistician somebody needs to do
that then we can say kind of like where
i'm going with this is moneyball you
know how in moneyball where the guy
comes out and he says look the only stat
that matters is what on base percentage
you don't win with home runs you don't
win well you won with unbased percentage
that's the guy that we need to bring
okay great then we bring him in then
they
interviewed that guy multiple
multiplications i love that guy so i
think a moneyball concept needs to be
applied to
this for us to figure out what stat
matters the most
i don't think we're doing that that's
what i don't think we're doing i think
we're just kind of all talking and
i'm sorry i would add one extra tick on
there what's that and you touched on it
roger a little earlier on
make a study of how many of the criminal
acts
with a weapon
that weapon was a legally obtained
weapon and in the hands of a legal carry
individual
that's a huge statistic
when people quote
gun violence you have to at least be
able to focus on where is the base of
that violence and it is the criminal
world
and do they don't have prosecution the
police can't can't barely do the job as
it is
um
it is that would be i would love to add
that to your your tickle for that i mean
i mean i get it that we have a campaign
you know where the campaign the manager
may say listen when it comes down to gun
violence here's the three points that
you have to hit boom boom boom that's
what you got to go and then just know
these 22 statistics see which one of
these you can remember and recite but
that's where you got to go but that's
marketing that's not we're not really
it's not really a solution we're just
marketing and saying hey if they ask you
to say that i'd love to have somebody
comes out and actually breaks this down
and say here's what it would have
changed and not change i don't know well
you're going to have that opportunity
we've now passed these laws
there'll be an election in two years
let's watch the violent crime statistics
for those two years and see if they
really change anything well no there's
going to be an election in
five months i understand that's probably
not in all fairness and not enough time
so let these policies be in place
they're going to be in place because i
don't see them being repealed
and you'll know in two years whether
they've made a meaningful change what
needs to happen almost immediately
is
bail reform because right now we have a
situation in almost every major city in
the country which they've done away with
bail
and criminals recidivist criminals are
right back out on the street many of
them to hurt people again
particularly new york city and new york
so uh
there's a i think something that has to
be reformed almost immediately so so you
know what i also would want to know out
of all these guys that did a mass
shooting what percentage is alive
what percentage is on the street what
percentages say is serving a life
sentence how bad was the
what do you call it the the price that
they paid for it is it purely all about
a uh uh uh what do you call a celebrity
you know the 15 uh
minutes of fame is that really what it
was all about has somebody taken all of
these guys and gone and done a document
documentary to interview every one of
these guys to come out with an analysis
to say this is the similarity we know
this job is that like this yeah
no no i don't think they're gonna so
even to pull up to see out of all these
mass shooting guys that how many of them
were from a single parent how many of
them had a father i want all of those
statistics to see what commonality do we
see
you can pull up that data then we say
listen
these three that you guys keep talking
about would only say five percent but
these two would have eliminated 42
percent let's address these two we're
not we're just winging it it's just like
is this something it's just
a a public
company or a you know a government
agency would you or
if i was a governor if i was a governor
of a state or if i was a president
i would go hire
10 engineers okay from silicon valley
and i would bring them from silicon
valley from the best places in the world
okay and i would bring them that
politically i would interview them to
make sure they're kind of like you know
how you're you hire a jury and you make
sure how they feel politically they're
not linked or any way they don't have an
opinion about the guy i would bring in
okay you guys are neutral perfect here's
three hundred thousand dollars per year
what's ten times three hundred thousand
dollars nothing chump change i want you
to pull up every data every stat every
everything you can
and give us the exact reason why this is
taking place if if the stats are out
there you can pull it up from the fbi we
can find that exactly this is not going
to cost that much money to do it's three
million dollars maybe a 10 million
dollar project hire the best analyst
guys data guys put them in the room pull
up all the data within 30 60 90 days we
can figure this thing out but here's the
problem with the data so the other day
you said we used this story there were
200 what does that sound by the way keep
hearing a sound like
oh i don't know so there were 226 mass
shootings in the united states through
whatever it was six months uh do you
know what qualifies as a mass shooting
it's four people if over four people
were shot not killed were shot
that qualifies as a mass shooting where
do you think the majority that comes
from
gang violence the majority of mass
shootings in the united states aren't
kids going and shooting up schools it's
not i mean it's it's it's gang violence
one and most of the again we cover this
most of the mass shootings happen with a
pistol not an assault rifle or a rifle
by the way all of that is part of the
data yes but i think the data can be
skewed but two it's it's
people don't want to address first of
all mass shootings
as they stand where it's gang violence
as opposed to mass shootings of
like you say mentally deranged people
walking in shooting people and those
kinds of things so again i think when we
say use the data again we have to
clarify what data are we using but tyler
that's also
in the insurance industry
actuaries actually do that as well they
break down by age where you realize you
know when we get table d rating on most
of the people that are table d are 55
and up or if i would live in this [ __ ]
place and a lot of them are from this
you can track nationality you can track
sex you can track married you can track
the you can track any of that stuff but
with what you just said i would add that
to the data as well yeah i would have
then i would say the mass shooting you
know what we would put on the mass
shooting how many people were involved
this one's four well 42 percent of them
are only four okay let's put that in
this category by itself 10 is 10 or more
let's put that in the category by itself
i don't think this is that complicated i
don't know if they want to find the
answer
i don't know if there will no because
they want to manipulate it they want to
tell you that there's 120 it's going to
take 10 million but you just gave 40
billion to ukraine it would take you 10
million bucks to figure this thing out
put people in the room get it funded
within a three-month period you get some
answers but we haven't done that i don't
know why we haven't done that well let
me add on to what tyler's saying because
you do bring up a good point if you saw
on the headlines
four people shot in the streets of
chicago you're like alright cool next
story move on with life we're so
desensitized to these types of stories
where america is at where most americans
are yearning are when we see dead
six-year-olds
innocent dead six-year-olds in a
classroom
there's i don't care if you're on the
left you're on the right we are
disgusted by this and that's what is
grabbing the headlines and that's what
why literally congress finally effing
did something and i think it's about
time whether it's optics whether it's
the sizzle or the stake remains to be
seen like roger said we'll find out in
two years if they've done anything but
we're [ __ ] sick of it we're sick of
dead kids in classrooms we're not sick
of what tyler's basically talking about
which is probably 90 plus percent of the
mass murderers is just
five people got shot on it's gonna
happen on july 4th weekend you can book
it down right now across america someone
in st louis shot five people whatever
next story keep it moving we are sick of
the classroom [ __ ] though
my point of this by the way
um people have to take emotions out of
these kind of decisions that's why i
like your
your document and dissect
because if you look at forget the four
people that get shot in new york or
whatever that that doesn't count but
schools mass shootings
in the last five years give me those
numbers
that happens in new york in three months
actually probably happens in new york in
two weeks you're saying just in the
streets just in the streets just on the
street so we you know we cannot focus on
the problem emotionally yes i personally
you know i cannot if i was in that
school i would have had to go in i
couldn't live with myself i could not
live with myself if i didn't go in there
and try to help him out
but
that is still a minority and it is it is
very serious and use that tipping point
to make things
make sense and i think that approach of
statistics not skewed the statistics uh
i think would help create a real plan
that they can implement so
i run one too many companies to do this
i would have taken i would have done
this myself as a project just to turn it
into a documentary through 60 even a
70-minute 75-minute documentary just to
go out there and say let me tell you how
what uh approach we took this here's the
problem here's the approach we took we
wanted to find out what's going on this
is the data we came up with okay and we
brought five people from the left
five people from the right five people
in the middle they all have strong
opinions we all want to find out we're
all open to finding out what's going on
what the solution is here's what we're
proposing to the world i would take that
approach so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]